EVERY LAWMAKER ARRIVED WEARINGA
VERSION OF THE UKRAINIAN FLAG AS
UKRAINIAN AS YOU GET.
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE DOES NOT DO
THAT OFTEN.
WHAT MCCARTHY DID NOT DO WAS
DAWN AN AMERICAN FLAG PIN.
>> KNOCHE NOT AT ALL AND OTHERS
WENT WITHOUT THAT, TOO.
IN THE CONTEXT OF LEFT NIGHT THE
AMERICAN FLAG WAS IRRELEVANT.
LOTS OF LEADER FOAL THAT WAY.
AT THIS STAGE THE FULL FORCE OF
AMERICA'S FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHITE HOUSE, CONGRESS, DEFENSE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES;
ALL REDIRECTED AVENGE THE
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
>> NOTICE THE VERBINGS AVENGE
NOT DEFENDS.
YAO LIKE TO THANK YOU WAS BEING
A WAY TO DEFEND UKRAINE FROM
RUSSIAN AGGRESSION?
THERE IS IN THE T. IS TOO LATE.
BIDEN'S STRATEGY FAILED.
PUTIN INVADE.
SHORT OF DESTROYING UKRAINE WELL
IS NO WAY TO LIBERATE BY FORCE.
ALL WE CAN DO IS PUNISH THE
RUSSIANS FOR WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS WHAT HE
PLANS TO DO.
WATCH.
>> LOST 30 THRS OF VAUCHL
RUSSIAN STOCK MARKET LOST 47% OF
VALUE AND TRADING SUSPENDED THE
RUSSIAN ECONOMY IS ROLING AND
PUTIN IS TO BLAME.
>> SOCIETY RUSSIAN ECONOMY IS
DESTROYED.
IMAGINE LIVING ISSUE THE
CURRENCY DROPS 30 POINT IN A
DAY.
143 MILLION RUSSIANS KNOW THEY
ARE POORY.
A HANDFUL HAD ANY ROLE IN THE
INVASION OF USHG CRANE.
MANY OPPOSED T. ALL OF THEM ARE
BEING HURT AS THEIR ECONOMY COME
ARC PART THAT IS FINE BECAUSE
THEY ALL DESERVE IT.
MICHAEL MC FALL THE FORMER
AMBASSADOR TO MOSCOW ANNOUNCED
EVERY PERSON IN RUSSIA BEARS THE
GUILT OF THE UKRAINE INVASION.
THERE ARE MOW MORE INNOCENT
RUSSIANS EVERYONE HAS TO MAKE A
CHOICE.
SUPPORT OR O MOEZ.
>> TO BE CLEAR, THERE IS NO
THING AS AN INNOCENT RUSSIAN.
OUR RUSSIA SCHOLARS TOLD US.
PUTIN GIVEN THE ORDERS TO INVADE
BUT 6 YEAR OLD GIRLS SHOULD PAY
THE PRICE BECAUSE THEY DESERVE
T. THEIR 80 YEAR OLD GRAND
MOTHERS DESERVE IT, TOO.
TO FIGHT TIR ANNIE THE UNITED
STATES MUST HURT THE CHILDREN TO
BRING JUSTICE THESE ARE OUR
VALUES BECAUSE VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
A MORALE MONSTER.
>> THESE ARE NOT TRADITIONAL
WESTERN CONCEPTS OF JUSTICE.
BUT BIDEN ENDORSES THEM AND A
COALITION IN THE CONGRESS.
THE QUESTION IS, IS THIS A WISE
COURSE?
WE CAN'T SAY.
FARFOR US TO SUGGEST THINKING
THROUGH WORLD CHANGING POLICY IN
ANY BAY BEFORE ENACTING THEM.
PAUSE TO REFLECT WE LEARNED IS
DISLOYAL.
ADULT MORAL CALCULATIONS ARE
TREASON THINK BURGLAR YOUR OWN
COUNTRY IS A CRIME.
ACT NOW ARE BE BE DENOUNCED.
HOLD JUDGMENT ON THIS.
WE NOTICED A QUESTION THAT BIDEN
FAILED TO ANSWER OR ADDRESS THAT
IS, WHAT IS THE POINT OF ALL OF
THIS?
>> PUT SIN BAD.
NO ONE WILL ARGUE.
BULL DESTROYING THE RUSSIAN
ECONOMY MAKE HIM LESS BACHLD
FORCE TROOPS TO WITH DRAW AND
HOW WILL THAT WORK AND HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE.
OR IS THE PLAN BIGGER THE IDEA
WE FORCE VLADIMIR PUTIN FROM
OFFICE.
OKAY.
WILL THAT WORK IN IF IT DOES
WORK, WHAT HAPPENS TO RUSH WHY
AFTER VLADIMIR PUTIN LEAVES?
WOULD THE NEXT RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
AN IMPROVE AM OR RUSSIA SDENDZ
TO CHAOS LIKE IRAQ AND
AFTERBEGAN STAN DID ONCE WE OVER
THROUGH THEIR GOVERNMENT.
YOU MAY NOT CARE BUT HAVE YOU TO
WONDER, WHAT WOULD BECOME OF
RUSSIA'S NUCLEAR STOCK PILE.
TAKE A MOMENT AND THINK.
ARE THERE POTENTIALLY WAYS THAT
THOUSANDS OF RUSSIAN NUKES MAY
POSE A LONG-TERM THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES?
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT NOT
THAT ANYONE IS.
THE IMMEDIATE GOAL THE
BIPARTISAN GOAL TURN RUSSIA TO A
PORE EYEA STATE.
NOT WHETHER PUTIN DESERVED THAT
IT IS MORE THAN MORAL QUESTION .
QUESTION IS, HOW WILL THAT WORK
OUT FOR US AND FOR THE WORLD?
AMERICAN CITIZENS HAVE A RIGHT
TO ASK THAT QUESTION.
>> START WITH HISTORY.
HOW HAS THAT WORKS WITH IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA THOSE COUNTS REALS
ARE CUT OFF FROM CIVILIZED
NATIONS ARE THEY PREDICTABLE OR
MORE OR LESS DANGEROUS TO THE
UNITED STATES.
COULD IT BE POSSIBLE THE STEPS
ARE COUNTER PRODUCTIVE TO OUR
INTERESTS?
THAT IS SOMETHING TO CONSIDER.
KEEP IN MINDS THE VERY PEOPLE
PROPOSING ALL OF THIS ARE THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO DEFUNDED OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND DESTROYED
OUR SCHOOLS AND TOOK DOWN THE
TEDDY ROOSEVELT STATUTE IN NEW
YORK.
ARMED THE TALIBAN.
DEVALUED THE U.S. DOLLAR.
BROUGHT HUMAN SLAVE REAR BACK TO
LIBYA.
THEY ARE GOOD AT WRECKING
THINGS.
PLANNED THE IRAQ WAR.
WHY WE MIGHT WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T WRECK ANYTHING ELSE
EVER AGAIN.
ONE THING BIDEN DID NOT ADDRESS
LAST NIGHT.
FOR OWL THE MORAL OUTRAGE HE
MADE NO MENTION OF CHINA'S ROLE
IN THE INVASION OF UKRAINE THAT
IS WEIRD MORE THAN ANY COUNTER
REAL CHINA MADE THIS INVASION
POSSIBLE.
CHINA IS RUSSIA'S MOST IMPORTANT
ALLI IN THE WAR AGAINST UKRAINE.
YOU GOTTA ASK YOURSELF AS
EVERYONE IS CULLPABLE, WHERE ARE
WE NOT TANKING CHINA CURRENCY
AND BANNING PLANES AND THE
YACHTS OF CHINA'S PEOPLE
>> WITH THAT, BIDEN WAS OFF TO
OTHER TOPICS BUT NOT WHAT YOU
EXPECT.
NEVER MENTIONED EQUITY.
WE CHECKED THE TRANSCRIPT THAT
IS VERY STRANGE.
EQUITY WAS THE KENT ROLL FOCUS
OF HIS ADMINISTRATION.
HE TOLD US THAT.
WE STILL HAVE THE TAPE.
>> OPEN THE PROMISE AMERICA TO
EVERY AMERICAN.
AND THAT MEANS WE NEED TO MAKE
THE ISSUE AND RACIAL EQUITY NOT
JUST AN ISSUE FOR ANY ONE D. G.
IT HAS TO BE THE BUSINESS OF THE
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT.
>> THAT IS A VERY ABRUPT CHANGE.
AGAIN, IT IS WORTH MARKING
BECAUSE NO ONE NOTICES THEM.
IN THE SPACE A YEAR EQUITY WENT
FROM THE BUSINESS OF THE WHOLE
GOVERNMENT NO AUDIO.
NOT AS POPULAR THAN THAT.
IN LAST NIGHT'S SPEECH THE ONE
LEFT SCRATCHING HEAD.
BIDEN SAID WE NEED TO FUND
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
THE ONES THAT HIS PARTY DEFUNDED
AND THEN, IN CASE YOU HAVE NOT
HAD ENOUGH BEERS.
BIDEN SAID WE MUST SECURE THE
BORDER.
WHY IS JOE BIDEN SAYING THAT.
FAR BE IT FOR US TO SUGGEST
THERE WERE POLES SUGGESTING HE
HAS TO SAY THOSE THINGS.
WE ARE START TO BEING CONCLUDE
THAT A FEW MINUTES AFTER HE SAID
WE NEED TO SECURE THE BOARD
EVERYBODY ANNOUNCED AMNESTY FOR
MANSLAUGHTER OF FOREIGN
NATIONALS WHO SNUCK IN.
>> PROVIDE A PATH WAY TO CITIZEN
FOR DREAMERS.
THOSE WHO TEMPARY STCHLTSZ
ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
REVISE OUR LAWS.
>> NOT THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS
IS ECONOMICALLY SMART THING TO
DO.
>> YES.
XHE ECONOMICALLY SMART THING TO
DO GIVE YOUR JOB TO A FOREIGNER.
DREAMERS, THOSE WITH TEMPORARY
CITIZEN, FARM WORK ANDS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
WHO DO YOU THINK COME ACROSS THE
BOARD ILLEGALLY THE MILLIONS IN
THE LAST.
NO AUDIO.
ESSENTIAL WHOA THEY ARE ALL
ESSENTIAL.
SO MOMENTS AFTER TELLING US HE
WILL SECURITY BOARD BIDEN
ANNOUNCED EVERYONE SNUCK ACROSS
GETS TO BECOME A U.S. CITIZEN
AND DEMOCRATIC VOTER LIKE
IMMEDIATELY.
IT IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
>> THAT WAS THE PORTION HE
TALKED ABOUT OUR COUNT ROW THE
FIRST WAS BORDERS ARE GO TO WAR
TO PROTECT OTHER'S BOARDERS AND
THE SECOND PART WHOEFRN SNUCK IN
GETS TO BE AN AMERICAN CITIZEN.
DOES THAT APPLY TO RUSSIAN
SOLDIER IN UKRAINE THAN KETANJI
BROWN JACKSON AN APPELLATE JUDGE
FOR A YEAR.
BIDEN SAID SHE IS OUR TOP LEGAL
MINDS
>> THE MOST SERIOUS
RESPONSIBILITY A PRESIDENT HAS
IS NOMINATING SOMEONE TO SERVE
ON THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT.
AS I DID 4 DAYS AGO, I NOMINATED
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEAL KETANJI
BROWN-JACKSON.
ONE OF OUR NATION'S TOP LEGAL
MINDS.
IS KETANJI BROWN-JACKSON ONE OF
THE TOP LEGAL MINDSES WE HOPE SO
MUCH BIDEN IS RIGHT APPOINTING
HER IS HIS GRAVEST
CONSTITUTIONAL DAUTS.
IT MIGHT BE TIME FOR BIDE TONE
LET US KNOW WHAT KETANJI
BROWN-JACKSON'S SAT SCORE WAS.
THE L SAT THAT WOULD SETTLE
WHETHER SHE IS A ONCE IN A
GENERATIONAL LEGAL TALENT
>> AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW THAT AND MORE BEFORE GIVING
HER A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT BUT
WE DID NOT HEAR THAT.
THAT WAS ONE OF MANY THINGS
BIDEN LEFT UNSAID ELUDED TO
RISING CRIME BUT NOT HIS ROLE IN
IT.
CLAIM TODAY IS GUN COMPANIES NOT
PROSECUTORS.
NOT THE CELEBRITY FUNDSES THAT
BAIL OUT MURDERERSES THAT MADE
THIS COUNT ROW DANGEROUS.
WATCH.
>> MAN HAS HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES HOLD 100 ROUNDS YOU
THINK THE DEER WEARING VESTS
REPEAL THE LINOCAINE SHIELD IT
MAKES GUN MANUFACTURES THE ONLY
COMPANIES THAT CAN BE 'VE CANNOT
BE SUED
>> FAR BE IT TO FACT CHECK
BIDEN.
THAT IS DISINFORMATION IT MAY BE
PUNISHABLE UNDER TREES OFFER.
WHAT YOU HEARD IS A LIE.
GUN MANUFACTURERS CAN BE SUE
TODAY HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
NOW THAT HE MENTION TODAY THERE
IS AN INDUSTRY IN AMERICA THAT
HAS TOTAL LEGAL IMMUNITY FROM
LAWSUITS THAT WAS GRANTED BY
CONGRESS.
HERE YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
SINGLE HANDEDLY TURND THAT
INDUSTRY'S CORPORATE EXECUTIVES
BY FORCING AMERICANS TO USE
THEIR PRODUCTS.
THEY HAD TO.
HERE IS THE BEST PART.
IF THE AMERICANS WHO WERE FORCED
USE THE PRODUCT IT IS WERE
KILLED OR INJURED BY THEM, WE
HAVE NO LEGAL RECOURSE THEY
CAN'T SUIT INDUSTRY OR COMPLAIN
ABOUT IT ON TELEVISION OR
MENTION IT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
NOW THEY ARE EXPERTS AND
PHYSICIANS AND NURSE THEY HAVE
BEEN SILL LENT.
YOU KNOW THIS PERFECT LOW LIMP
BIDEN KNEW THIS HE WAS FLACKING
FOR THE COMPANY WHEN IS HE GOT
TO THE PODIUM LIKE THE CREDIT
CARD COMPANIES IN DEL DEM MANY
OF THE PEOPLE AR